في اسرائيل قال في في رئيس هيئه اركان
الجيش المنتهيه ولايته ان تنسيق الامنيه
مع السلطه الفلسطينيه يعمل بشكل فعال وان
الجيش الاسرائيلي وسعى من عملياته في
منطقتي جنين ونابلس بسبب ما سمه ضعف عمل
الاجهزه الامنيه الفلسطينيه هناك كما
انتقد كخافي تعيينا سيموتريتش زعيم حزب
الصهيونيه الدينيه وزيرا اضافيه في وزاره
الدفاع ومن القدس تنظم الينا مراسلتنا
نجوان سمري نجوان عن هذه التصريحات
نسالك عنها ما ابرزها دلالاتها خاصه فيما
يتعلق بالضفه الغربيه
وانتقاده تعيين سيمو ترتش
نعم بدايه تصريحات كوخابي تاتي في سياق
انتهاء عمله وتسلم هرتيها ليفي مقاليد
رئاسه اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي مطلع
الاسبوع الماضي الا بهذه التصريحات ضمن
مجموعه من المقابلات الصحفيه لغلبيه وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه
وحاول بطبيعه الحال الابراز ما يصفه من
جانبه الانجازات التي حققها الجيش
الاسرائيلي خلال ولايته عندما تحدث عن
الجانب الفلسطيني فهو تطرق الى الضفه
الغربيه وايضا الى غزه وقال بان العمليه
التي اطلقها جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
العام الماضي تحت اسم كاسر الامواج كان
لها حققت اهدافها كبيره من خلال
الاعتقالات التي نفذها الجيش في الضفه
الغربيه ولكنه ايضا تطرق الى قضيه التنسيق
الامن قائلا لان الاجهزه الامنيه
فلسطينيه عندما لا يكون بمقدورها التصرف
في مناطق معينه مثل جنين ونابلس فان الجيش
جيش الاحتلال يكثف من عملياته في المثل
هذه المناطق تحديدا علما ان جيش الاحتلال
يواصل عملياته في كافه انحاء الضفه
الغربيه وليس فقط في منطقتي جنين ونابلس
من شمال الضفه وحتى جنوبها عمليات
الاقتحام والقتل والمداهمات تتواصل وهو ما
حدث ايضا قال ايه يوم امس وحيث قتل
الاحتلال خمسه فلسطينيين في 24 ساعه ومنذ
بدايه هذا العام نتحدث عن سبعه شهداء
وعندما تم سؤال همم كخافي عن ان العام
الماضي يوصف بانه الاكثر دمويه وان هذا قد
يرشح الوضع الا الانفجار قال بان الجيش
قام
باحباط ما وصفه بالعمليات التخريبيه
الفلسطينيه مئات العمليات وهو لا يتوقع ان
يكون هناك انفجار همم مقترب رغم ان كافه
التقديرات السياسيه والعسكريه تشير الى
امكانيه تفجر الاوضاع اذا ما استمرت
الجانب الاسرائيلي بهذه الممارسات
المتواصله ضد الفلسطينيين على الجانب
الاخر في غزه قال بان الجيش حقق ما سماه
الردع مقابل حركات المقاومه سواء كان حركه
حماس او حركه الجهاد الاسلامي وتباها
بالعدوان الذي شنته اسرائيل الصيف الماضي
على غزه واستهدفت به قيادات حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي لكن العنوان الذي يتفاعل اكثر
همم في الوسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه من
على تصريحات همم كخافي كانت تصريحاته
بخصوص الاتفاقيات الائتلافيه التي حولت
صلاحيات لبنت الايه السموتر وزير الماليه
وعيانته كوزيرا اضافيه في وزاره الدفاع
ونقلت له صلاحيات الاداره المدنيه وعمليات
تنسيق الح الاسرائيليه في الاراضي
المحتله وايضا صلاحيات
لقوات حرس الحدود التابعه لجيش الاحتلال
نقلت ايضا بموجب هذه الاتفاقات الائتلاف
الاتفاقيات الائتلافيه الى ايثمار بن جرير
وزير الامن القومي انتقد ذلك كخافي
بالعاده المسؤولين المسؤولون العسكريون في
اسرائيل يتجنبون الحديث في السياسه ولكن
من الواضح مع نهايه ولايه كوخابي فانه
تطرق الى ذلك وقال بانه لا يمكن للجيش
الاسرائيلي ان يتلقى تعليمات من اكثر من
وزير ومن اكثر من جهه وبان الجيش سيتلاقى
التعليمات فقط من قبل وزير الدفاع وهي
رساله تحدي واضحه لبنك كبير وايضا اسمه من
جهاد رد عليه مباشره سمود لم يتاخر في
الرد وكتب في تويتر مهاجما
قائلا بانه لابد بانك خافي يمهل لدخوله
الى المجال السياسي في هذا التصريحات وقال
لربما انه
لربما ان كخافي نسي بان اسرائيل دوله
لديها جيش وليس العكس وسيله شكرا من القدس